[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thank you, so much,
for the introduction.
This is going to
be a joint talk,
but I'm the one who will
set things in motion.
So as mathematicians, we
like to express things
as simply as possible, and
I'm going to jump directly
into the problem.
So this is a polygonal chain.
Trivial, right?
So a bunch of points
connected by straight lines--
they can live in 2-D, in
3-D, in arbitrary dimension,
if you are adventurous.
But for the time being, all the
illustrations that I will make
will be in 2-D.
OK, so what is special about it?
We view it as a bar-and-joint
framework or linkage.
We want the length of the
distances between the points
that have been marked there with
an H to retain their lengths.
We mark the lengths, and
we don't want to change it.
However, we've
allowed the joints.
The joints allow rotation,
very much like our arms
can rotate about our joints.
So this is a bar-and-joint
polygonal chain.
So in case you think
it's too abstract,
here's a little demo that
I picked up from the web.
This is a robot arm from
the Canadarm from the Space
Station.
It's a robot arm, rigid
links with rotatable joints,
and it's performing very
important tasks up there.
So that's why we refer
to this polygonal chain
sometimes as robot arms.
Now, here's a robot
again, very small clip,
just to whet your appetite.
This doesn't look like a
serial linkage, just a polygon.
It looks like a
branch structure,
but the arms, the
legs themselves
are these polygonal linkages.
So we are also interested
in closed polygonal chains.
And at this point,
you will think, why?
Well, here's an example.
This is a robot that carries
a tray, and the arms, together
with the torso
and the tray, form
a closed polygonal linkage.
So what do we want
to do with this?
Let's say you get your
tray, you pick it up,
and you want to
move it somewhere.
You have to reconfigure
your polygon
from one initial
position to a final one.
So this is the polygonal
chain reconfiguration problem.
We have to design some
motion, so let me demonstrate
one possible reconfiguration.
Yes, how it would look like.
Remember, we allow
rotations, but we want
to maintain the edge length.
So maybe it looks like this.
You start moving a little bit.
Now, these are lines.
OK, maybe that's what I wanted.
So another one, maybe.
Yeah, but you notice that
several move at the same time.
And finally, I'm
where I plan to be.
What I'm trying to argue
throughout our talk,
what we are trying to
argue throughout our talk,
is that there is a
hidden structure.
And in fact, we want to
discover this structure.
We may not know apriori.
In fact, it's not visible.
So I will demonstrate
it to you, and then I'll
tell you how we model
it mathematically.
Although it's not
visible, it is what
can guide motion, what can
help us design trajectories
and further on to applications.
So on the left, we have
the polygon in motion.
On the right, I'm going
to add extra structure.
Remember, the structure
is invisible to you,
but I'm adding it.
So here is what I'm doing first.
I'm using extra bars.
They are those added red.
And as I add them, I eliminate
the freedom to move, yes?
So it is as if my arms--
all of a sudden, I'm
hitting something here.
So I turn a join that was
very flexible into a part that
is rigid.
OK, so I'm arguing,
and then I'll
explain in more detail later,
that the structure on the right
is rigid--
completely rigid.
It doesn't move at all.
So what I'm going to do instead,
I'm going to remove one edge,
and it's going to be selected
in a particular way--
namely, on the exterior.
In mathematical language, on
the convex hull of the planar
linkage.
I'm going to remove it.
I still left it there
with a dot to suggest
maybe something
like a rubber band,
because I will
allow that to flex.
I'll allow that to move.
But the rest, the
red bars, are going
to keep the structure
partially rigid,
if you want to
describe it that way.
So now, with this, I
have the freedom to move,
and the two things move.
And although on the left you
don't see it, on the right,
you see that it's guided.
It's moving in such a
way that the red bars
retain their lengths.
So now I got again get to
something that is fully--
it's close to my target,
so I'm going to freeze.
I'm going to lock that joint.
I'm not going to
move it from now on.
And now, if again you
do a little calculation,
you will realize that this
one is completely rigid again.
So we have to drop another
bar from the convex hull,
get another structure
that moves and moves
along a very
well-determined trajectory,
until it reaches the goal.
And again, I locked that joint.
I drop another one, and then
I conduct the final motion,
and I'm done.
That's my final structure.
That's the goal.
That's where I wanted to get.
OK?
So now, this hidden
structure can
be explained in terms of
an area of mathematics
called rigidity theory.
So let me give you
a brief introduction
to rigidity theory.
So this object living
in the plane is rigid.
It means that it can
do things like this.
You can rotate, translate
it in the plane,
but it doesn't change the shape.
The shape remains the same.
And in fact, any
collection of triangles
would have this property.
Well, when you built a
structure from bars and joints
as big as this
one, you definitely
want it to be
rigid, not flexible.
OK, so on the other hand,
from bars and joint,
we can also build
purposefully structures
that are flexible mechanisms.
So this is the simplest one.
It has one degree of
freedom in the sense
that by rotating that
joint about the other one,
there is only one
way to rotate, yes?
So there is only one
force or only one motor
that will activate the
joint in the robot arm.
So we call it a one degree
of freedom structure.
But the one degree
of freedom structures
can be more intricate.
So for instance, this is
the next, the simplest one,
the next one that
you can think of,
and it is a closed
loop a [INAUDIBLE]..
And I'm telling you that this
one has one degree of freedom
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, so it moves roughly like
this, and at some point,
it may even cross itself, yeah?
Can go back.
So it has one degree of
freedom, and these pieces
with one degree of freedom
are very useful because they
move only in one way.
Otherwise, if I have too
much freedom to move,
it's hard to design the motion.
Maybe you design it one step
at a time, one joint at a time.
It's easier when it can go
only along a single trajectory.
So our goal is to understand
those single trajectories,
those trajectories that can be
described by placing extra bars
and getting these one degree
of freedom structures.
So now, these structures
are very famous.
I'm showing you here
a very famous one,
the so-called
Peaucellier Linkage
discovered in 1864 at the peak
of the Industrial Revolution.
It's the one that
converts circular motion
to linear motion.
It was a famous open problem.
So on the right, I'm
showing it to you
because it's the same
linkage, but it's clear
that it's planar, at
least in the plane.
And as it moves, you see
that some of those links
actually overlap.
So it's possible that these
linkages are more complex
than just polygonal chains, than
just closed polygonal chains.
They may have many links,
and in particular, they
may even cross.
Here's another one.
This time, it's in 3-D. And
in fact, I have it here.
This is the Hoberman Sphere.
It's a bar-and-joint linkage.
And again, it moves with
one degree of freedom.
You just pull in any
direction, and it expands.
It stops at some point,
and you move it back.
So what I want to do now is to
analyze the hidden structure
in this reconfiguration motion.
As I said, the polygon has
too many degrees of freedom.
But as we add bar, we restrict
those degrees of freedom, yeah?
So we put people behind bars
to restrict their freedom.
Sorry for making the pun,
but I wanted to retain that.
More bars you add,
less freedom you have.
So if I add enough of
them, I can no longer move.
I'm completely rigid.
This particular one, yeah?
So this particular one is rigid,
but it's rigid in such a way
that if you remove any
bar, it becomes flexible.
It's called minimally rigid.
So if I remove one bar from
this minimally rigid structure,
I get something that is
one degree of freedom.
But I'm going to
remove a special one.
This one's from the
convex hull, yeah?
And I get this one
degree of freedom
a la Paucellier Linkage.
And then, well, it's
like I rotated the crank,
and then this one
keeps moving, yes?
So you already have seen
this, until an event happens.
So the motion now is decide
what one degree of freedom
structure you want.
Move it as long
as it's possible.
I could continue, but I have
a hidden reason to stop there.
And then, reconfigure.
So drop another bar, yeah?
So freeze, drop another bar, and
continue until the bars align
with joint, lock, and continue.
So in order to explain, right?
So until the whole
chain is convex--
in order to explain what
is going on, first of all,
what do you think with
this kind of motions?
Are we actually
avoiding collisions?
Could it be possible that
something is so intricate-- not
in this particular case, but
something is so intricate
that as I move stuff, maybe
I will produce collisions,
very much like in the
Paucellier Linkage?
And so I don't expect you
to give me the answer,
but remind you that it is
possible to get collisions.
But in this case,
the answer is clear.
There are no collisions.
And the reason why now has to
be explained mathematically,
and in order to do
the explanation,
I need to introduce
the concept, yeah?
So one was the one
degree of freedom motion
that you have seen.
The other is the concept of
what an expansive motion means.
So let me start with
that little definition.
So expansive motion--
OK, expansive means when--
it's very much
like this one, yes?
If I choose two
points in this motion,
these points move
away from each other,
but not only these two points
move away from each other.
Any other pair of points moves
away from each other, yeah?
So an expansive
motion would be one
where all the points that
I'm keeping an eye on--
they move away from each other.
It's like an expanding
universe, yeah?
So let's say we may
start with three points,
and we just move them
away from each other.
If there are no constraints
between the points,
I can do that easily.
But if there are constraints,
like if I have a framework,
then let's see
what happens, yeah?
So let's keep an eye on the
evolution of the length.
So this one started 6.87.
The other is 2.4.
And I'm going to
increase this big one,
and you'll notice that
the other one also
increases simultaneously, yeah?
So they increase, increase until
this one, the big one, yeah?
So reach its maximum--
of course, beyond the maximum,
it can no longer expand,
so it would start decreasing,
although the other one
increases.
So it's like all of us.
We have an expansive
period in our life,
and then at some points along
some dimension, we increase.
Along others, we decrease.
So mechanisms have
one degree of freedom,
but their trajectories,
their full trajectory,
is split into intervals.
And it's only on one interval
that you can fully increase
in all possible directions.
So that is what happened
with this structure, yeah?
So if I start in this
shape, I'm expanding.
I'm young and expanding.
And then I reach the maximum.
OK.
I got the fellowship at
Harvard or something, yes?
I hope I will
continue, but you know,
it's maximum on some dimension.
Good.
So these are the definitions,
but I give you some very simple
examples, but the
reality is that we fully
understand these structures.
So let me tell you quickly
about the structure of 2-D
expansive motion, and I need
to introduce one more concept
to the triangle.
So we see here a triangle.
Everybody knows
what a triangle is.
We have seen this little object.
It's a pseudo-triangle.
These also are
pseudo-triangles, and here's
how you can recognize one.
You recognize it because it has
only three points on the convex
hull.
So there is sort a hidden
triangle behind the scenes.
And where it is not
on the convex hull,
it bends inwards in
a concave fashion.
So these are
pseudo-triangles, yeah?
So all of these
on the background
of their supporting triangle--
and when I put them together, I
obtain a pseudo-triangulation.
So here's what it means.
And this is a game
that you can play.
And I challenge you.
Go home.
Take your friends,
children, whatever, spouses.
Draw a bunch of points in the
plane randomly, like here.
OK, so I draw them.
And then, your task
is to obtain a tiling
of the convex hull
of these points
into pseudo-triangles, yeah?
So you see here, each of these
pieces, if I would cut along
these bars, I would get pieces
that are pseudo-triangles.
So let me color them so that
you will see them, yeah?
So the challenge
is how to do that.
Maybe it sounds trivial,
but let me show you very,
very quickly how you
can play this game.
Basically, you
play it at random.
Just throw it
anything, randomly.
However, you have to
respect some rules.
So for instance, I don't
allow you to do this.
Why that?
So the first rule is I want
you to keep enough space
around each vertex.
Around each vertex, you
should have an angle larger
than 180 degrees.
When I added this edge,
I violated that rule
because now I have angles
that are all smaller than 180.
So I'm not going
to add this one.
That's the first thing
that you have to avoid.
The other is don't
produce crossings.
And if you avoid these two
rules, then at some point,
there will be
nothing you can do.
You try this.
You try that.
Everything will violate.
And if you look carefully,
all of these faces
are pseudo-triangles, OK?
So now, this is the structure
in an expansive motion
that we want to start
describing in our project.
We discovered this years ago.
So here's theory number one.
First of all, a
pseudo-triangulation
is always minimally rigid.
First of all, it's rigid,
and removing any edge,
it becomes flexible.
And when you remove an edge
from the convex hull-- and also,
the mystery is clarified now.
So when you remove
from the convex hull,
then it becomes a one
degree of freedom mechanism
and always, always
moves expansively, yeah?
So it's not just
those little linkages
that I have shown
you, but all of them.
And you can build them tonight.
Random points-- your
children can build quickly.
OK.
So once again, this is
my expansive structure,
and I move it.
And I want to notice
that usually, I
have to stop when
something aligns
because beyond that point,
it starts shrinking.
So this one is an expansive
mechanism, but remember,
it's only for a given interval.
OK, so that's a structure.
Now, the beauty of this is
that this is essentially all.
You don't have to look further.
A one degree of
freedom mechanism
is essentially any
one degree of freedom
expansive mechanism
is essentially
a pseudo-triangulation with a
convex hull edge removed, yeah?
So it's a characterization.
And not only that,
if now you want
to do any motion that
it's expansive, in fact,
it's a complex combination
of such structures.
So if you understand
the structure,
you can describe any
possibility in what
is called mathematical
or convex combination
of the original ones.
So we have a full
characterization.
And I would be really happy if
I could extend this to dimension
three to have a
theorem that does
the same thing in the
dimension [INAUDIBLE] higher.
Unfortunately, that is not such
a thing for various reasons
that have to do with
famous open problems
in mathematics that have
been open for over 150 years.
But since we are here,
putting everything together,
the problem with I started with
is that every planar polygonal
chain can be convexified
in a finite number of steps
using this expansive
pseudo-triangulation mechanism.
So that's the first structure in
motion that we plan to present.
So it can be applied not
just to simple structures.
It can be applied
to complex, convex--
sorry, complex, very convoluted
polygons like this, to large,
very large.
And we would like
to do it in 3-D,
but I let you know
what we can do in 3-D.
So first of all, remember that
this Canadarm on the Space
Shuttle is short.
It just has a few linkages.
We don't need a complicated
algorithm to handle it.
It's not closed.
It's open, but it is in 3-D.
We'd love to understand how
to move this in 3-D. However,
for the 21st century, things
that seemed completely
irrelevant, for instance,
for the engineers of the 19th
century--
you don't need too
many bars in order
to build interesting mechanisms.
But I remind you of
something that Kepler
said in a famous writing.
"Where there is method,
that is geometry."
So we are going
to look at matter,
and these are nature's robots.
This is a video that I picked
up last night from the internet.
And what you see here are what
are called molecular markers.
These are proteins that perform
their functions in my cells,
in your cells, in millions and
trillions of cells as we speak.
And they are made of--
they're like little mechanisms
at this time with tens
and hundreds and thousands
of these linkages,
and even hundreds of
thousands of such links.
And we like to
understand how they work.
So this is an artist's
rendering of what
happens in the cell
with dynein and kinase,
two of these molecular
motors transporting cargo
along the microtubules
in the cell.
Now, these molecules
are made of proteins,
and the connection with the
chains that we will be talking
about is that the
backbone of a protein,
which looks like this big blob,
is, in fact, a polygonal chain
living in 3-D. So this is one
of the motivating problems
for the project
and for everything
that we conduct from there on.
So again, let's see,
how large could they be?
How many could they be?
So I did a quick
search yesterday,
and the Protein Databank
is the data bank where I--
the software that we have
designed in my group.
We get the structures, and
there were 145,000 structures.
Last year about this time,
there were about 130,000.
So it grows with over
15 structures per year,
and accelerating.
Just to give you a very,
very quick idea about what
is going on, this started
about 40 years ago
with structures that--
each one of them was worth a
Nobel Prize, like myoglobin.
And these by today's
standards are small proteins.
They were considered
huge by those standards.
Nowadays, the largest one
in the Protein Databank
is their atomic-level structure
of the HIV-1 virus capsid.
This has about a
2.5 million atoms.
And this is another virus.
Each time I get the
flu, I'm thinking
about how beautiful they look
in these computer-generated
images.
They are very
symmetric, so we have
to put some symmetry,
some mathematical theory
to put it to work so that maybe
we can analyze them faster,
because for the
following reason.
So what you see here
is a generated image.
But while the experimental
is [INAUDIBLE],,
it's more something like this.
So this is a cryo-EM
image of a virus,
and you see it in two states.
It's obvious that it flexes.
It's obvious that
there is motion there.
So this is as it
enters your body,
and this is where it releases
the dangerous nucleic acid
inside to infect your cell.
So we'd like to understand
how this happens, and here's
an engineer's view of this.
Parts of the structure
seem to be moving rigidly,
and others seem to
allow freedom to rotate.
So very much like our
linkages, except that now there
seems to be collective
motion, pieces,
collections of atoms
that move simultaneously.
So that's what we want
to understand next--
collective motion.
So actually, we have seen
it, but it was hidden.
So let me show it again, yeah?
So let's get this
mechanism that moves.
Can you track some points that
seem to be rigidly attached
to each other?
And not everything is moving.
Not all the points are
moving away from each other.
Those that stay rigidly
attached to each other form
what are called
rigid components,
and I highlighted them here.
And now I'm doing
the same motion
with and without
the colors, and you
can see that the colored
pieces move together.
That's a collective motion.
So here's what we have done.
So a couple of years ago, this
started as a collaboration
with a biophysicist, and
we have this software
that is called KINARI--
Kinematics and Rigidity
Analysis for Proteins.
And what it does, it
takes a protein structure
from the Protein Databank and
does a coloring of the pieces
that if the protein will
move and it moves, then those
will tend to stick together.
So it's very precious
information about the stability
and about the overall
behavior of the structure.
So let me give you,
quickly, two applications.
So this can be used to
predict, for instance,
the effect of binding a ligand.
This is a protein--
HIV protease.
And it's here
without the ligand,
without the extra
molecule that is designed
to fit in that little cavity.
And here is with
that ligand, and we
can infer the effect of the
ligand on the protein rigidity,
and maybe this gives us
some functional information
about the role of the
protein in the organism.
In particular, if we do this,
we notice that these two flaps
here, which the biologists know
they have a functional role.
They have a functional
in the spread,
in the division of the--
in the multiplication
of the HIV virus.
And when that little drug
is injected in the organism
and binds there, it's rigid,
and those flaps cannot perform
their function,
which is-- basically,
they act like scissors, OK?
So we infer functional
information from this.
This is work done by a group
demonstrated in about 2002.
Our goal is to be able
to provide a tool where
this can be used
on a larger scale,
not just on a few proteins.
So we infer.
We hope that with
this kind of analysis,
we can infer function from
structure on this large data
set of proteins.
So here is another one.
Everybody has heard
about mutations.
So what you see here
is the same protein,
but a little mutation has
happened so that certain bonds
cannot form.
And you can see that
large, rigid cluster split
into two, which tell us that
this one actually is more
flexible than the original one.
So probably, its function
might have been affected, OK?
So these proteins,
the majority of them,
have been solved with
a technique called
x-ray crystallography,
meaning that they are not
just one, single structure
that we are looking at.
They are many.
So the problem becomes large.
So how can we algorithmically
handle such challenges?
So we want to understand the
structure in periodic motion.
And at this point, Ciprian
will take over and tell you
about that.
[APPLAUSE]
- Our periodic structures
are widespread in nature,
in man-made materials.
And we see here, by
now a famous structure,
of course ideally drawn, but
this is one sheet of graphene.
So it's an illustration
in dimension 2
of a periodic structure.
Here, I make it stand
next to a drawing which
suggests three dimensions.
So let's look first at a planar
one on the left, where you'll
notice the color
code of the vertices
because they will assist to
visualize the periodicity.
So if we translate this
structure, imagined
extending indefinitely, then we
can superimpose it over itself.
So periodicity,
briefly, is expressing
this translational
symmetry of the structure.
And if we watch, say, a red
vertex by this translation,
which necessarily takes hexagons
to hexagons and triangles
to triangles, these symmetries
will always take a red vertex
to a red vertex, a
blue one to a blue one,
green one to a green one.
And all these
collection of vertices,
which we call orbits
and periodicity,
express the symmetry of
the periodic structure.
On the right, we have the
diagram of a crystal structure,
actually, which is
important for artists,
because this crystal structure
is involved in making pigment
for the color called
oftentimes Prussian blue,
and the famous wave of Hokusai
uses that kind of blue.
Another source of
periodic structures
comes from sphere packings.
So sphere packings
have been imagined
since the time of Kepler,
and the dates here
is a summary of the
famous conjecture
he made that the best, the
densest stacking of spheres
of the same radius is
this kind of stacking.
And Gauss showed that as long
as you assume periodicity,
that's indeed the case.
But what if we don't assume
periodicity and just allow
the stacking to be disordered?
And [? Hale's ?]
recent contributions
were to show that even in
the absence of assuming
periodicity, this is
the densest packing.
On the right, we see
what a mathematician
would do with the structure.
You'll take into account
the contact graph.
So each sphere is considered
as a node or vertex.
If two spheres are in contact,
you put the bar between them,
and this gives you a
contact periodic framework.
And you look at its
generators of periodicity.
So those three red
arrows indicate
that if you translate
with those vectors,
the structure will go
over itself exactly--
of course, imagining
it infinite.
So here's a simple
example, which
goes back to the
quadrilateral used earlier
in Illeana's presentation.
So we start with a
humble quadrilateral.
And we are going to adopt
the two diagonals, which are
the red arrows, as our periods.
So I'm going to take
this humble quadrilateral
and translate it by that
vector, then by this vector,
and begin to generate
its infinite array, which
you see progressing over here.
I have put these two at
the adequate distance
so that you see that
completed to a larger piece.
But we want to imagine
for mathematical purposes
the actually infinite
periodic structure.
So you see that surreptitiously,
there's a doppelganger here.
And if we call it that,
we'll see the pattern.
So this is called the
double arrowhead framework
because of how I started
with a single quadrilateral.
The periodicity construction
creates that sibling
of the image of
the quadrilateral,
and that's the
expression of a theorem
that in dimension two,
if you have just two
orbits of vertices,
there's always
this addition of symmetry.
So it's not by accident that the
two are essentially congruent.
So how is such a
structure moving?
Well, now that we have seen
that a single quadrilateral does
have a one degree of freedom,
we just say to ourselves,
well, I can repeat
the same procedure.
I take the diagonals as
periods and do the thing,
and indeed, we will see that
it moves because of that.
And here we go, and it seems
to expand both vertically
and horizontally.
And we look with more
intensity, and it does so.
It even goes out of the
space of the screen.
But by now, I'm reaching as
in Illeana's illustrations.
I'm reaching a point
where two edges align,
and my quadrilateral has
now the shape of a triangle.
And beyond this point,
I become convex.
And you will see now that
[INAUDIBLE] vertically, I
increase the structure on
the horizontal direction.
I'm now retreating.
You see?
It comes back.
And [INAUDIBLE] I go
beyond, and it retreats.
So this is leading
us to a notion
which became very important
in modern materials science--
the notion of auxetic behavior.
And this diagram
will communicate
in the most direct terms
what this behavior means.
So on the left, if we have
a conventional material
with some elasticity--
and I invite
you to imagine a bar of rubber.
If you pull it, as
the arrows indicate--
so if you want to stretch
it, it will stretch.
And laterally, it will shrink.
But this is the most
typical behavior
of the vast majority
of natural materials,
but in some instances, this
less intuitive type of behavior
was observed--
that you may pull and
stretch the material--
say, vertically,
in this diagram.
But at the same time,
laterally, instead of shrinking,
this type of material
expands as well.
So this is the short, intuitive
definition of auxetic behavior.
It involves lateral
widening upon stretching.
And we have now the challenge,
if we go back to this view
here, now, I indeed
increase in both directions.
By the way, the word "auxetic"
comes from the Greek word which
means tendency to increase.
So we can take with a less
precise definition than before
that auxeticity is
a form of growth,
but it cannot be excessive in
one direction and too modest
in another.
It is a rather balanced
form of growth.
But growth cannot be indefinite,
at least at the bounded rate.
So its auxetic behavior
will occur for some time
and then stop.
And in the spirit of our
search for hidden structure,
we asked ourselves, well, what
is the necessary geometrical
underpinning of this behavior?
And we'll show the answer
for the structure at hand.
So the answer is that ellipse
is responsible-- the existence
of that ellipse is responsible
for the auxetic behavior.
I'll keep it for the time
a little mysterious how
it comes about,
because you see, if we
have just the quadrilateral,
the ellipse is not there.
So this is a feature
of the periodicity.
But there are many conics that
you can [INAUDIBLE] around,
because in geometry,
we learn that if we
have five points
in the plane, there
is always a conic through them.
This can be an ellipse,
a parabola, a hyperbola,
or it can be degenerate,
two lines, or a double line.
And that was known at
the time of Apollonius,
and of course, that was
influential for Kepler later on
to explain the planetary motion.
And here we have an ellipse now.
What I want you to
observe is that we
are at one type
of vertex, and we
look at all the edges
emanating from it.
I have these four edges.
So with the origin and the
extreme of these four edges,
I have my five points.
And I trace the conic
and the ellipse,
and that explains
the auxeticity.
If I move and come
to this iteration,
I watch the same five points.
I draw the conic,
and it's a hyperbola.
So something has
changed in-between,
and indeed, the auxetic
behavior must have stopped
before getting to a hyperbola.
So this humble conic
is the key indicator,
and we want to watch
now this transition.
I am auxetic.
I'm expanding both
vertically and horizontally
until this is now a
very elongated ellipse.
And now, the ellipse has
degenerated into two lines,
and this is the transition
to the hyperbola.
So now, although I'm still
increasing in one direction
laterally, I'm receding.
So this is not auxetic anymore.
So we see that the finite
situation, the pseudo-triangles
for finite linkages,
reappear here
because both the
initial quadrilateral
and its doppelganger are in
the auxetic configuration
pseudo-triangles.
But now, if we have
a tiling like that
with a periodicity
and pseudo-triangles,
then we actually always
have one degree of freedom.
And as long as the
pseudo-triangles remain,
the pseudo-triangles
will expand.
When some alignment
occurs and we
lose that pseudo-triangle
property, things may change.
Now, to approach
our conclusion, I
would say that the
theory is not restricted
to dimension two,
which was chosen
for the simplicity
of the illustrations.
It's actually valid in
arbitrary dimension.
And the fact that we could find
this hidden structure related
to conics, or in [INAUDIBLE]
dimension, ellipsoids--
is that we approach the
matter with a purely geometric
definition of auxeticity.
So this is the definition.
I admit, it has a
more technical flavor,
but in essence, it
says the following.
I have a periodic structure.
Well, what is most important
for a periodic structure?
Its periodicity.
How can I express
it in finite terms?
I take just the
generating translations.
So that's a bundle of
vectors, exactly as many
as the dimension.
Now I codify them
in a matrix, which
is called a gram matrix,
from a Danish mathematician
of the 19th century
by the name of Gram.
So that makes the idea that
the Gram matrix is just telling
me what happens to the periods.
And as a single entity,
it traces a curve
in the space of
symmetric matrices.
But this space is not
like any space of matrices
because of symmetry.
We have there a notion
of positive definiteness.
So in short, the space
of symmetric matrices
is not bland.
It has more structure.
It has this cone of positive
semi-definite matrices.
And this is immediately
inviting the analogy
with a Minkowski space
in special relativity,
where we have a cone of light.
And this matching is literal
if we are in dimension two
because two-by-two matrices
make a Minkowski space.
But in higher
dimension, this cone,
which is depicted here
like a Minkowski cone,
is actually more complicated
because higher dimensional,
semi-definite cones have
a more complex structure.
But it is very well
studied mathematically,
and it's implicated in many
branches of mathematics.
So it's not an
exotic object at all.
So this says we can
engage auxeticity
in arbitrary dimension.
We are not tied
to the dimensions
of experience two and three.
For materials, we can
fancy auxetic behavior
in arbitrary dimension
because the geometry
works just the same.
So here, I want to summarize
with another drawing what
the result is.
So I need the
initial illustration.
If you'll recall, I
had an illustration
with red, green,
and blue vertices.
That is the pattern here.
It's, by the way, usually
called a [INAUDIBLE]
periodic structure because
of a Japanese pattern
of weaving or basket-making.
And here, I retained
only the essentials.
So you see some of the red
vertices, some of the green,
some of the blue.
And the key to understanding
the structure--
you choose one vertex
in one color or width,
and you look at another
or, say, the green.
So I have this point
connected to two green points.
They are just three points.
Now, through three points, I
have a two-dimensional family
of conics--
in particular, ellipses.
So that this is
not telling me what
ellipse should I draw there.
But I know that if
auxetic, I need an ellipse.
If I move now to a green, I
will need an ellipse through
the green, and it's--
no.
So if I move to a green vertex,
I need an ellipse through this,
and it's connected blues.
And if I move to a blue,
I need an ellipse so
its connected reds.
So I will need three ellipses.
They must be now--
ready for a mathematical term?
Homothetic.
They must be
homothetic ellipses.
This frightful word means
something very simple.
I can only take an
ellipse, and I'm allowed
to translate it and rescale it.
That's homothety--
translation and dilation.
That's it.
Now it's not frightening at all.
In particular, you will have the
same orientation of the axis.
Well, my three ellipses
are conditioned
by being in this
brotherhood or sisterhood
of being in a homothetic family.
And moreover, this
detail of the diagram
says that if I go from
my vertex of origin
to the center of the ellipse in
the three homothetic ellipses,
I satisfy a cycle condition.
Those vectors add up to zero.
So these conditions,
in fact, are precisely
those imposing the
unique solution.
So with this explanation,
you see that ellipses there
are uniquely
determined, in fact,
but they would be totally
invisible, totally hidden,
if you don't have this
disclosing theory behind.
And you'll have a
slide with formula.
Here it is.
But generally, if you
distill the matter,
it can be expressed
in these two lines.
So what do we know?
We know that the bars must
preserve their length.
There's the question expressing
it, but in lattice coordinates.
So since periodicity
is so important,
it gives me a
system of reference,
and I use coordinates in
that system of reference,
not necessarily the fixed
Cartesian background.
But I can differentiate in
any system of coordinates,
and that's the
infinitesimal equation.
Now, our geometric
definition of auxeticity
says that this
tangent, this omega
is that Gram matrix I tried to
make friendly a little earlier.
So this says the tangent to the
trajectory of the Gram matrix
is positive definite.
And then, to a
geometer, that equation
immediately says,
oh, we have a bundle
of homothetic ellipsoids.
So that's a geometrical
explanation of auxetic motions,
and I will conclude with a
little animation of motion
in this very common
crystal, quartz.
It's silicon dioxide,
and in this diagram,
what we see is just
the tetrahedra formed
by oxygen atoms.
So the [INAUDIBLE] is roughly
at the center of the tetrahedra.
But for the purpose of
motion, the chief element
is that these tetrahedra are,
for a good approximation,
remaining rigid.
So we have a
bar-and-joint structure,
and there is a flotilla
of ellipsoids, which
will explain the motion we see.
But it's quite
numerous, so it would
be difficult to portray
all these zeppelins
in the diagram, so the motion
is now contracting now,
genuine auxetic.
And this is something
that happens
in the so-called alpha to beta
phase transition in quartz.
If you heat quartz, it goes
from a less symmetric structure
to a higher symmetry at a
certain high temperature.
And this is the back
and forth of the story
of quartz and that transition.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]